[Music]
hello in a very warm welcome indeed to
quite Auriga coming to you from the
heart of Berlin and the dust is just
beginning beginning to settle after
Sunday's national election here in
Germany the vote handed Chancellor
Merkel and historic fourth term in
office but it was a bitter victory with
her conservative slumping to their worst
defeat in the post-war period and the
far-right alternative for Germany party
entered the Bundestag for the very first
time with just under 13 percent of the
vote how will a weakened Merkel respond
domestically and internationally our
question on quadriga this week after the
election what now
Frau Merkel and to discuss that question
I'm joined by three keen observers of
German politics beginning with andreas
Clute of handles but global the
english-language version of that
publication
who says angular Merkel is now a lame
duck and we'll get weekers her fourth
term progresses but in a world of
bullies dictators prima donnas of trump
skims putin's and heroines she remains
our last best hope
note the word last that's interesting
also with this is political analyst
Verna zona formerly a very familiar
figure on the ard TV network he believes
that Europe needs Angela Merkel's
leadership more than ever but after her
devastating election setback she faces
the desperately complex task of forming
a new coalition and a warm welcome to
Tabasco Moog correspondent for the
French weekly magazine Latoya she says
with the weekend Angela Merkel Emmanuel
macron dream of a fresh start for Europe
is suddenly much more complicated much
to talk about advisor begin with you
Pascal
tell us if you would give us a little
bit of a flavor of how the election
outcome here in Germany has gone down
with all the surprises it brought with
it I think it was a big shock in France
and probably a big disappointment for
Emmanuel macomb who two days ago
made a big speech about Europe
presenting his vision of Europe for the
future and he was sure that if the great
big coalition
I mean SPD and CDU the Socialists
was rican reconducted he had the chance
of at least realizing partly his program
but now it's going to be very difficult
with the Liberals partly with the greens
as well and I think it's a it's a it's a
bitter feeling you have in France that's
at last the French are back on the
European scenes with the young
presidents who want to introduce reforms
who has ideas about Europe and now the
Germans are going to be at least the and
until Christmas discussing this new
coalition I mean you know everybody it's
very funny because everybody was saying
all the Germans are so boring it's going
to be the same as usual they want
continuity they don't want to expert
experimentations and now here we are
with big experimentation no continuity
and a little bit of chaos in Germany
undress you have been nodding all the
while I couldn't agree more I mean I was
I was smirking when you know the Germans
do have this reputation they love order
they're a bit boring they're gonna sort
this out and moti Merkel is the best
person to do it and suddenly it has
become I thought it was interesting all
along actually it wasn't boring but
suddenly it is becoming a real
cliffhanger with the possibility not a
probability but a possibility of
actually failure so not just
negotiations that at least lead to
Christmas and beyond
but even coalition's that lead nowhere
at all and then possibly new elections I
don't think that's likely
but it Germany is from the point of view
of France which is very important to
Germany since the election that because
of the German worry that lepen could be
the one next time
Merkel was really hoping all over for
several months - for this time to help
McCraw as much as she could that is on
hold for the time being for the reasons
Pascal just mentioned mmm vanna vanna
Sona how much has Angela Merkel's
political mandate been weakened in the
last few days it has I've gone of course
been weakened a lot no doubt about it
but the chaos is too strong a word
clipping or I think is the right
description right now this is where we
are and it will take a while and
we have no government in the Netherlands
we have had for one and a half year no
government in Belgium and life continued
and therefore the same thing will happen
here in Germany we are not we are not
politically dead we do have a working
government and therefore we will see a
very very very complicated and complex
attempt to form a new government very
open-ended no doubt about it but the
world can rest assured Germany will
continue to do as its job there is a
face of insecurity around us no doubt
about it but in the end because there is
no alternative to this government nobody
wants new elections it will happen the
only question is when and under what
conditions and the conditions will be
very very complicated the voice of
reason there I not sure that I quite buy
into what you saying just to get a feel
for how apparently shell-shocked Angela
Merkel appeared after this vote we have
this short statement from the Chancellor
let's listen to it and then talk some
more
I don't know what we could have done
differently I put a lot of thought into
this election campaign and I ran it the
way I planned it speaking a must
what do you say fair now I mean I when I
look at that I see Angela Merkel who is
normally so cool calm and collected
looking
I need a C word clueless yeah clueless
is absolutely the right word when it
when we just try to describe the the
current major players it's even worse in
Bavaria right now
there that the word is really big
clueless
definitely and it was very almost
shocked when I heard Angela Merkel on
Monday saying we did everything okay
there was no need to change of course we
can't go on like saying Vytas or let's
move on like we did before
that's impossible in German politics
right now they need we do need a change
no doubt about it and but the central
question is how we achieve that goal and
before Uncle America can really enter
into any meaningful negotiations about a
new government she has to clarify her
relationship with our sister party CSU
will talk about that in just a moment
Andres I just want to hear a little bit
more about Angela Merkel how you know
how how her psyche is at the moment you
know the the the financial time said she
has taken a hit that was quite evocative
her psyche I think Merkel I once wrote a
large piece just about her body language
I think which suggests she has I talked
to her psychologist about this low
cortisol level she does not get stressed
as easily as as other people get
stressed I actually happen to think even
though this situation is intractable
she's probably the least word bad or the
best person for it so her psyche I'm not
worried about
she said something very interesting in
the roundtable discussion on television
on election night that income there is
strength that is Ramat oh so she's gonna
stay calm and as you know her principles
to slow things down the fact that things
will will be slow and will take work
she likes to decelerate things observe
allow others to make mistakes so I don't
think her psyche is really is as
destabilized I just think the the world
the political world in Germany around
her has actually changed she's in a new
situation that will render her weaker
hmm what are you telling your
in France about where these coalition's
might go how long they might take and
how much jeopardy how much risk there is
involved in all this I think I think
just to come back to what you'd been
saying I mean I think calm and
self-control is indeed in this world
where you have so many luly's over hunt
is a very good quality for a leader
especially for a German leader and
because this is a very important country
but I find Angela Merkel a little bit
stubborn and almost deaf I mean it would
be very important for listening you're
saying she's not listening to her people
I mean more than 1 million people who
normally vote for her deserted her to
vote for party which is the best
populist nationalist at the worst hushed
extreme right with revisionists
undertone I mean something quite nasty
and she says yes we have to get these
people back but I don't hear enough how
to get them back I don't hear enough you
know you you really have to react now
against that and let's see if this
coalition will manage to get these
people back but you have to take these
people seriously
vanna and i think an aspect of the
problem that Pascal is talking about
there is that which we have rediscovered
with this election is that Germany is a
divided country east and west the
alternative for Germany getting
something like 11% in the in the win the
west of the country and twice as much in
the east of the country in the state of
Saxony a very influential and important
state in Germany there are actually the
strongest force yeah in that state
definitely yeah it's pretty obvious this
is the case and one can regret it and
one has to regret it but that's the fact
and she has to offer answers I mean she
comes from the east but she never really
offered I never portrayed herself as
coming from really coming from the east
you wanted to be the Chancellor of all
Germans rightly so but these people need
answers for the Voorhis and it's for an
outsider's very hard to explain what's
really going on there in the East
because when you travel to the east and
when you see all these cities and towns
rebuild blue in the lunch often as
Helmut Kohl once
that it really created them big time and
and then it's very hard to understand
what's really going on in in these five
states and but the fact is but people do
not really identify with West Western
Germany they never arrived there and
this is obvious now more obvious than it
has been and therefore the angular
maracle and the other parties as well
need to offer new answers that's just as
complex as that is okay let's just get
some pictures now go back to the the
pan-european challenge now facing
Germany and other European countries
from the aft and other similar parties
in those other countries Sunday's
election was a political triumph for the
AFD the party will have more than 90
seats in the Bundestag this is a warning
for German politicians the people want
something different the German people do
not accept Chancellor Merkel's migration
policies to the extent that they have
been implemented dr.tofu
right-wing parties now have seats in the
parliaments of twenty you states that
gives the party leaders confidence their
presence is beneficial and we will
continue to work on building the Europe
we want goodness Whittle Austria's
freedom party has expressed similar
sentiments ahead of parliamentary
elections set for October goal is to
keep control of our country that's what
we intend to do we have high hopes
what sort of Europe do the right wing
parties actually want
[Music]
it's a good question Pascal we know that
they are anti-immigration anti-islam
anti-foreigner anti-eu are these
populist parties across Europe now a
genuine threat to the EU itself yeah I
mean it's it's threats it depends how
much they are not in the government
that's the first thing I mean they have
a lot of impacts in in terms of
influence and voice and median presence
but they are not in the government and
so they are not able to make the laws or
to decide anything so that's a good
thing it's definitely I think what
Emmanuel mark wanted two days ago
is to try and rejuvenate to get some new
energy to the European idea and that's a
very good thing that a young man is
going to be 40 in December
that's another generation to take that
the the real a I mean we know that the
older generation who's known the war in
France in Germany are very Pro European
now it's this young generation these
globalized generation he speaks perfect
English that's the first president we
have in France who speaks English I mean
you have to imagine who speaks German we
have a prime minister who studied in
Germany who lived in Germany yeah so
it's a globalized generation and if this
generation tries to revive and to make
the people clear how important it is to
be united in this world which is very
complicated and it's better to be a
European bloc then if every country is
acting for itself but people are very
frightened and interesting I just wanted
to say that interesting is that the IFP
vote I have their voters the right
extreme right voters in Germany do not
vote because they are frightened of
losing or it's not the main issue is
they are frightened of using their
economic strengths they vote because for
ethnic and cultural reasons they are
frightened that their culture will be
taken away their language that they've
been invaded by Islam so it's this you
have to count down people and reassure
them
okay so Emmanuel macron is the
antithesis to the anti EU and to euro
zone far-right let's just listen very
briefly to what he had to say earlier in
the week when he really threw down the
gauntlet to angle America
and I'm proposing to Germany a new
partnership we will not agree on
everything immediately but we will
discuss everything those who say that
the task is impossible my answer is
you've become pessimistic
I have not Andreas tell us a little bit
more about Emmanuel macron vision for
Europe but what he might or might not
get from Germany now of what he might or
might not get from angular Merkel whose
hands are tied a little bit after this
election I sense I think a lot of his
proposals are would have gone down quite
well with the German elite just before
the election more collaboration and
foreign and security policies all of
which are things that make good sense
but the the important one and the one
that's going to cause the problems
during these negotiations coalition's is
his call for a common eurozone finance
minister a common eurozone budget of
fiscal capacity which the greens in the
in the coming coalition talks are for
which the Social Democrats would have
been for but they bowed out which some
was which which Angela Merkel herself
might have even entertained but which
the Bavarian sister party the Christian
social Union and the Free Democrats
rigidly and stubbornly will oppose
because they would they think they fear
getting punished yet again by voters
because they they fear that is the
beginning of a slide into a transfer
Union from their point of view where
Germany will permanently subsidize other
countries and they want to avoid that so
this will be one of several key sticking
points and and one reason why because
it's the big issues that not the small
day they will compromise on the small
issues but it's actually this time the
big issues where they won't get on the
same page what are people saying about
Christie and Linda the the head of the
Liberal Free Democrats here in Germany I
mean McCraw apparently told friends
ahead of the German vote if the Liberals
enter the government which they look
likely to do if these coalition talks
work out he said it I don't know what
the French word wasn't but he said I'm
done for
I will be dead he said yeah yeah I will
be dead well I don't know he just said
in this little film that he needs you
need to be optimistic so let's be
optimistic but there are chances that he
will be dead
Lina is not at all known in France and
now we're discovering him and he's been
compared to there's a big difference
different the teacher I would say in
those is macron gonna get a deal from
Germany well I'm wait to go isn't yellow
of course you have to look at what
Angela Michel had to say about yesterday
is through her a spokesperson and he
said in her name that she is praising
his speech big time it was very
important that he did raise all these
important issues issues but in the end
she did not support his ideas and this
is what we are facing now nobody in
Germany really wants a transfer Union
this is the center the most important
point nobody wants that and nobody can
push it through it is and and and and
nevertheless it there is some real
substance to what he has to say Europe
has to come out of of the status quo it
has to move forward but the question is
how and and therefore it's important to
say this new coalition will not be
anti-european the question will be how
could we move Europe forward but
definitely not with the transferor Union
where Germany is going to pay big time
for the other countries especially in
this house Christian Laettner actually
said earlier this week if the idea is to
use a common euro zone budget to set up
a cash pipeline flowing from Germany to
other European states that's something
we simply won't go along with exactly
what I just said yeah Andres know that
that is one of the energy climate policy
the diesel diesel gate crisis those are
the others those are some of the others
and of course refugees is perhaps the
biggest but we could just stay with the
eurozone for the
take of that and there is one reason why
I'm probably more pessimistic than you
that these negotiations can succeed mmm
let's talk a little bit more broadly
about what Angela Merkel can and cannot
achieve on the international stage you
you said in your quote at the top of the
show that she is our last hope
yeah our last hope for achieving what
and why the last one she stands I mean
it is interesting right now her stature
outside of Germany especially in North
America by the way is gigantic in even
parts of Asia it's it's only in Germany
that where we're close to her and we
hear her in the original German where we
consider a week now but what does she
stand for she stands for a multilateral
not a unilateral world instead of
America first Germany first China first
she stands to for all of us together she
stands for cooperation she stands for
opposing violating the borders of
sovereign states as Putin did in Ukraine
she stands for what we used to know
including free trade and an open and
global world as opposed to a closing
world of reen analyzation that's what
she stands for and that's what we used
to call the liberal world order it was
premature to call her the leader of that
order and she herself has said that's
grotesque because that's what German
leaders must do German leaders since the
war have to keep a low profile and to
manage expectations down but that's
where she is
the only possible partner she has on the
shall we say multilateral and globalist
and open side is Emmanuel macron mm-hmm
so how is she now currently seen in
France she told us about him anyone
might crawl what about Angela Merkel in
France a franchise this was very
interesting during the whole campaign
the whole campaign focused on Angela
Merkel and she's a sort of goddess in
France or somebody she we like the
French like her can ability to make
compromises she's not corrupt like the
French politicians she's very low-key
she's a muti there's a lot of admiration
a little bit like Gorbachev who was not
so much like in his own countries but
adored outside I mean it's it's in
France it's
very very clear and I think even if
she's lost a lot of power now the French
are very relieved that she's there to to
stabilize this very humourous world at
the moment I think 80% of what you do
just rightly described as as the virtues
of Angela Merkel will be supported by
her coalition partners there's one
dividing thing and that is a big one and
at this immigration how we deal with the
immigration problem
and there are you see a huge difference
especially between the CSU her sister
party the party leader who are CEO for
the Bavarian prime minister and Angela
Merkel and and and and the central
question here is the limit well they
have will they put a limit on the number
of refugees that can come to Germany the
CSU wants this
definitely and Angela Merkel is risk or
is resisting this and so do the Greens
and probably we'll see what the FDA in
the end will really say about that but
this is the sticking point and therefore
they have to find a solution and nobody
really knows how this will come about
and and therefore it as I already stated
it's the most important question is how
well or if Mackel is ready and able to
reunite with the CSU if this is the the
most important question that that she
has to attack right now and until she
has reached an agreement nothing will
move forward in these negotiations I
think if I may sort of generalize this
to we're seeing across the West
times have changed so much that the
traditional party landscapes are being
shaken up you saw that Trump is not a
traditional Republican neither
Republican nor Democrats knew what to
make of him or Bernie Sanders in manual
oh rick mcgraw blew up the party
landscape and came with his own i think
if you look at this conundrum that we're
in here in germany
Germany is overdue for this kind of
shake-up and even though the Germans
like it stable I think it's coming one
of the things for possible future show
is I can't see if you said five or ten
years out I cannot see this partnership
between this Christian social Union and
Christian Democratic Union that's lasted
for seven decades I cannot see that
lasting much longer they're gonna go
their separate ways
sooner or later and I think they're just
not willing to admit it yet the question
here is who is the new Trump in Germany
was the new macaw in Germany we only
have Angela Merkel for the time being
or do you use does anybody see anybody
who's going to mention another name yeah
you know which name is it yeah
definitely but you're not gonna mention
it fighting against each other and
there's the rumour that the party might
split in two so you know it's not the
strongest of formats you're not in
France not as organized I've got to draw
on venez encyclopedic knowledge of
German politics in the last decades
we've got a fourth term Chancellor there
have been two that have gone before
Helmut Kohl and Konrad Adenauer what can
you tell us about what clues that might
give us about how this is gonna pan out
well in the end people were tired of
Helmut Kohl and that is why he lost the
elections and that will eventually which
is because it is a very normal process
will eventually happen to Anglo market
doesn't sound like it for this
discussion no no no not not not anytime
soon but whether she will be in office
in four years from now I don't know I
have you know I just don't know but it
could happen to her like could happen to
him would call and it's always very
complex for a politician to find a way
out my theory is that Angela Merkel has
looked at both Konrad Adenauer and
Helmut Kohl and concluded that they
failed in two ways they did not allow a
successor an heir to emerge and I think
she will in this term decide to allow
one to emerge and that's why she's a
lame-duck one sentence
[Laughter]
I'm gonna turn away I'm gonna say the
name that we were talking about this
phonebook that's a good'n back here the
former German Defense Minister we've got
to go now I can hear the music thanks
very much for joining us hope we've
given you plenty of food for thoughts on
what next for angular Mackel bye-bye
and truce
[Music]